all right let's look ahead now to new
year's eve that's coming up next
thursday
and we have new details now on the party
on fremont street so they
are allowing people there on new year's
that's according to their website
earlier this month we told you the area
still did not have permission from the
state
but there's a section of the website it
says wristbands are 25
those can be bought online or at hotels
on fremont gates will open at six
there will be no live entertainment that
night but you can go apparently john and
presumably less people allowed yeah less
than the video we're seeing there to be
sure
now there are no fireworks on the strip
this year although there will be the
fireworks on the plaza downtown
las vegas boulevard will not be shut
down this year because of the changes to
the
parties however ndot is planning some
road closures around the strip because
of the new year celebrations that are
taking place so here are
some of the closures to watch out for on
new year's eve north and southbound
off-ramps on i-15 are going to be closed
at the tropicana frank sinatra and
flamingo exits
traffic will also be blocked on
tropicana going east at industrial and
eastbound on flamingo and valley view
all roads are going to be back open
between three and six in the morning
on new year's day plan ahead alex
yeah and join us that night too we're
gonna count down in 2021 right here on
channel eight
with kirsten and brian our show kicks
off at nine o'clock runs through 12 35
this year
we're gonna take you through every time
zone starting over in new york city
ending right here in las vegas and we're
going to be live
inside circa we're so excited to show
you that beautiful property
we're also raising money for food banks
across the country any money you donate
will stay
right here in las vegas and the local
communities if you would like to donate
you can find more information on our
website
eightnewsnow.com but we're excited to
see you for that next thursday